I think
one thing about technology is that
there's this idea that sort of culture
is separate from technology
and that people are separate from
technology
and that these things are on two sides
of a line
I think that's really not only incorrect
but it's often damaging technology is to
further Humanity full stop
[Music]
foreign
I started Kindred adventures in 2014 as
a solo capitalist and one of the First
Investments that I made from that was
coinbase I had come from consumer
software and the consumer internet and I
learned a ton about how to build these
much more heavyweight Industries like
marketplaces and Logistics
moving forward I started Angel Investing
more and more I had not only invested in
30 or 40 startups by that time but I had
also learned so much
about how to help
startups how to help Founders as another
founder as a fellow founder and I really
enjoyed that zero to one stage that
going from like one or two people and
coming up with a concept that they were
very excited about and then being able
to help them not only as an angel
investor with some Capital but also as
someone who can empathize with their
experience
[Music]
at this time period this is when
there was sort of a shift in thinking
about Founders and operators being
investors might be a good thing
and that seems sort of obvious today
but back then it was unclear
San Francisco and Silicon Valley and
California this Progressive mentality
that it Harbors has been a great driver
this is why people from around the world
come here because they know that they're
in a place that Embraces them we can't
lose that in California and we certainly
can't lose that in San Francisco
[Music]
our company is called Humane we are
about 220 people now based in San
Francisco and we've been building since
2019 on the belief that AI will be the
base of the next generation of compute
and we knew back then that we felt that
there needed to be an entirely new
device and an entirely new platform to
allow for the mass consumer to really be
able to experience it and become super
powered by AI yeah
I think the thing that really attracted
us to Steve was his approach to building
companies
is similar to the way we build product
it we have a philosophy that really
starts with what the experience of the
product should actually be and we work
our way back from that he gives very
direct and open and honest feedback and
guidance and advice and sometimes in the
moment I I'll like walk away thinking I
wonder why he's thinking that and then
later realized that you know he he has a
Long View he's thinking what does this
mean for Humane 10 years out 20 years
out
[Music]
it's hard for a lot of people to
articulate what exactly they're looking
for but it's up to Founders to build
that
it's just been a pleasure to back teams
like that and we we want every
investment to feel like they're not just
following
what the teacher May hold but actually
helping create and shape what that
future might look like
[Music]
a friend of mine had moved from Canada
to San Francisco and his name was
Garrett camp and he had an idea about a
black car with a driver being able to
pick you up based upon you requesting it
on your phone
and this app idea was a side project and
he asked me one day to help him work on
it and so I helped him start the company
as an advisor so it was called The Uber
cab in the very beginning those early
days was so so important to later on how
I sort of built a framework for myself
on how startups can come from many
different origin points
I feel grateful to be have been a very
small part of that journey in the
beginning and to be able to stay close
to the company but I'm mainly in awe of
the startup journey in that it can
result in a company like this
it's still a pleasure to see the company
grow as a global Service under the new
management and I think Dara and and team
here have done an amazing job of
continuing the growth
[Music]
one of the things that I really loved
about moving to San Francisco was the
art the music
food culture all of that and it wasn't
just for wealthy people it was for
people entrepreneurs and creative folks
that wanted to do something differently
and wanted to be the best at what they
were doing and so one of the things that
I've tried to do is support the Arts
here
I think that's really important I've
backed restaurants local Street artists
music venues
I think
part of what we do in Venture is to pay
it forward to new Founders to help them
build out their Vision I also think we
should be doing that with our community
[Music]
Huska is a place for to convene people
we brought a the CEO of Gucci and the
caring group management team here to
talk about web3 technology and they
loved it
and that's a very San Francisco thing to
take a craft take that attention to
detail take inspiration from everyone
else out there and and from their own
lives wherever they came from
so you just got into my head that hey we
enjoy all these things they're
entrepreneurs too we are investing in
each other so that we can improve our
community's life
San Francisco is going through its
problems as any big city is today
but you know I think what the best thing
that we have for each other is a smaller
tight-knit Community we can invest in
each other who's thick and thin
foreign
[Music]
startups a long time ago I used to go to
this restaurant next door and people
would frequently come by and tap me on
the shoulder on their way out and say
I really love the food tonight thank you
so much I was kind of confused and and
the manager told me that hey that I
think it's because the chef looks like
you the chef de cuisine the CDC and I
laughed I said you got to introduce me
to them
his name is Brandon Jew he's born and
raised in San Francisco Chinese American
and you know an amazing fine dining chef
but really wanted to break out on his
own and start his own restaurant and at
that time
you know there was not much happening in
Chinatown so he was really the first and
he helped Revitalize it by creating Mr
Jews which is both a restaurant a lounge
a banquet hall for the community and a
bakery shop and a cafe all in one
[Music]
where we are right now is the very first
Blue Bottle Cafe it's really just a
garage and a cart and it's it's the very
first one I think it opened in 2004 and
I lived up the street it really like
opened my eyes up to the idea of third
wave coffee this new sort of more
thoughtful in terms of where the beans
were roasted and how the beans were
roasted and where the the beans were
sourced and and things of that nature so
was able to invest early with them
and that's been a great experience
as an investment in not only you know
what they provide to the city in our
community it's somewhere that I can go
to in Tokyo now in Seoul and London and
New York and la and that's been an
amazing journey to watch
I ended up being able to help them enter
and expand into Japan and Korea which
was really exciting and fun my family is
originally from Korea with also some
roots in Japan and so it was really fun
to help them launch in Tokyo and Seoul
and enjoy that
I think it's putting putting our
industry to task to say Don't just
complain
don't just give us your wish list but
support creators entrepreneurs artists
Builders real Builders like Atomic
Builders right designers restaurants
chefs be able to support them
in the community that you choose to be
in
[Music]
Steve does this for love in fact I bet
Steve would would pay to do this that's
how much he loved it and and when I say
it I mean just working with Founders he
loves rolling up his sleeves and getting
into the getting into the muck and and
really trying to help early teams figure
stuff out and and so as a result his
passion and his enthusiasm is pretty
authentic and it's very organic and that
really resonates with me because we can
sustain ourselves through hard times
when you're doing it for love and and
then the second I guess is he's been
doing this a long time and so he is I
always refer to him as like a Marco Polo
of startups he's tried every spice and
so as a result he can bring some real
wisdom to bear on behalf of startups
across different areas of Technology
every conversation that we have with
Steve is always so inspired energized
and always so helpful in these early
days when we actually started to build a
company and it was just a small crew
even now he's been a big part of our
series C as well he's just got such a
really precise vision of how to execute
alongside Founders it's there's there's
really just no other way to describe it
we're grateful to be involved when
they're ultimately successful
and we're also grateful to them if
they're not successful and they have to
shut their company down because we've
also learned so much along the way
we're just fired up to be able to have
that relationship for the Long Haul
from starting the company all the way to
you know hopefully after IPL
but even if not IPO if they're the
company doesn't work out and they start
a new company we want to again be their
Ally and help them on that Journey so
this is a lifelong commitment that we're
making to our founders
true partnership and this is really why
you know it's we name the fun Kinder
Adventures how do we understand the
psychology of our Founders so that we're
not sort of one size fits all in our
approach how do we understand the type
of product or technology they're working
with how do we play the right role right
and have that great investor and founder
fit that we're looking for so these are
the things that we can control these are
the things that matter to us the rest is
up to the founder
[Music]